[Musique]
le rock'n'roll les motos les petits
pavillons de banlieue des personnages
roublard et attachant quel meilleur
guide pour en parler que l'auteur lui
même
manu c'est un
personnage un peu teigneux c'était
j'avais créé manu parce qu'au départ on
voulait faire un dessin nul avec lucien
et j'avais déjà fait beaucoup de
musiciens je me suis fait très sympa de
créer un nouveau personnage donc j'ai
fait un et pointu pas pour le distinguer
de lucien
l'idée était vraiment de d'essayer de
montrer petite rétrospective de son
travail donc présenté à la fois ces
grandes séries donc le personnage de
lucien est inévitable mais aussi manu le
petit personnage qui avait été créé pour
la télévision mobile coursier qu
apparaît dans les années 2000 la
carrière de dessinateur de frank
margerin commence à la fin des années 70
ses thèmes de prédilection son univers
renvoie beaucoup de visiteurs à leur
jeunesse
globalement ce que j'aime bien chez
margerin c'est à son humour
j'ai rencontré des bandes dessinées
j'étais tout petit grâce à mon père
voilà qui était fan de bd et j'ai connu
fluide glacial voilà il me tall hurlant
et donc lucien le rocker le motard et sa
vie ni mon enfance
lucien que margera fait vieillir en même
temps que lui apparaît grisonnants et
bedonnant en 2008 l'auteur joue ainsi
sur les décalage générationnel
fois regard bienveillant sur les
nouvelles générations quand on était
jeunes c'est une parenté ou des
grands-parents qui a qu'apprécier pas
trop passer la musique c'est une musique
de zazou qui faisait du bruit les
cheveux longs c'était par les filles
enfin j'ai eu quelques réflexions de mon
père à l'époque donc j'essaye de ne pas
faire pareil avec nos fils mais je
dirais que quand il fait écouter du rap
je fais
est alors moi je fais écouter du rock il
a annoncé chez
les traits de crayon et traits d'humour
de frank margerin sont exposés à la
médiathèque de montargis jusqu'au 30
septembre
[Musique]